Simplifica la expresión usando exponentes racionales
y tenemos la raíz cúbica de todo esto lo cual,
es equivalente, por definición,
a 64 por "a" a la sexta por "b" cúbica por "c" a la novena, todo esto elevado a la 1/3.
Estas son iguales, como hemos,
dicho por definición.
Y si tenemos el producto de estas cosas
que está elevado a la 1/3,
eso es lo mismo que elevar cada una de estas cosas a la 1/3 y después realizar la multiplicación,
así es que, esto es lo mismo que
64 elevado a la potencia 1/3 por "a" a la sexta elevado a la potencia 1/3
por "b" al cubo elevado a la potencia 1/3  y finalmente, por "c" a la novena elevado a la potencia 1/3,
y esto ya lo hemos visto varias veces
en vídeos anteriores.
Ahora 64 a la 1/3, esto es igual a 4,
pero si no es evidente para ti,
siempre puede ser una factorización de primos,
esto va a ser igual a 4, por si acaso no es obvio para ti, que 4 al cubo es 64,
entonces te sugiero que hagas
una factorización con números primos.
Vamos a hacerlo,
vamos a recordar cómo se hace la factorización
por números primos,
entonces 64 es igual a 2 por 32,
32 es 2 por 16, 16 es 2 por 8,
8 es 2 por 4,
finalmente 4 es 2 por 2,
tenemos entonces 64 es 2 que se multiplica
a sí mismo 6 veces, 2 a la sexta,
aquí tenemos
2 por 2, por 2, por 2, por 2, por 2...
2 a la sexta, o 2 por 2
multiplicado por sí mismo 3 veces,
2 por 2 es 4, así es que estamos multiplicando
4 por sí mismo 3 veces, 4 al cubo,
entonces, si no resulta evidente para ti
que la raíz cúbica de 64 es 4,
siempre puedes hacer la factorización
como lo hicimos aquí
y darte cuenta que 64 es 2 elevado la sexta potencia
ó 4 elevado al cubo.
Te dejo entonces que pienses sobre eso,
entonces,
si este de aquí es 4 elevado al cubo y eso lo estamos elevando a la 1/3,
eso es exactamente lo mismo a...
mejor déjame escribirlo aquí abajo,
para que se vea más interesante...
entonces, tenemos que 64 es 4 al cubo,
lo cual estamos elevando a la 1/3
así que esto sería 4 por 3 a la 1/3,
vamos a ponerlo aquí abajo.
Este término aquí es 4 por 3 a la 1/3,
que es 4 elevado a la 3/3, 4 al cubo y eso a la 1/3,
y luego aquí tenemos "a" a la sexta,
y eso elevado a la 1/3...
"a" a la sexta elevado a la 1/3, "a" elevado a la 6 por 1/3 ó "a" elevado a la potencia 6/3,
y luego tenemos "b" al cubo elevado a la 1/3.
Hacemos lo mismo que hemos estado haciendo,
multiplicamos los exponentes, esto es "b" a la 3 por 1/3, que es "b" elevado a la potencia 3/3,
y luego tenemos "c" elevado a la novena potencia
y eso elevado a la potencia 1/3,
eso va a ser "c" elevado a la potencia 9/3.
Ahora, simplificando los exponentes,
este primer término de aquí,
4 elevado a 3/3 es 4 elevado la 1
ó simplemente 4,
"a" elevado a la potencia 6/3
es "a" elevado a la 2 ó "a" cuadrada,
luego tenemos "b" elevado a la potencia 3/3 que es
"b" elevado a la 1 ó simplemente "b"
y finalmente tenemos "c" elevado a la potencia 9/3
que es "c" elevado a la 3 ó "c" cúbica.
Y así hemos concluido.